A grim national record has been set in Orlando, Florida, the deadliest mass shooting in US history. It's being investigated as an act of terrorism. Every time there's a terrorist attack, we ask ourselves, what could motivate someone to commit mass murder? Although it's still early in the investigation, we know enough to say that this was an act of terror and an act of hate. Officials say 29-year-old Omar Matin called 911 to pledge allegiance to the Islamic state during his rampage inside the Pulse, a gay nightclub in Orlando.
美国佛罗里达州奥兰多发生了一起惨绝人寰的全国性惨案，这是美国历史上最为致命的大规模枪击事件。目前，该事件正作为恐怖主义行径进行调查。每当发生恐怖袭击时，我们都会扪心自问：究竟是什么驱使一个人犯下谋杀众人的罪行？尽管调查尚处于初期阶段，但我们掌握的信息已经足够让我们断定，这是一起恐怖主义行径，也是仇恨的行径。官方表示，现年29岁的奥马尔·马丁在奥兰多一家名为“脉搏”的同性恋夜总会内大开杀戒时，曾拨打911宣誓效忠“伊斯兰国”。
Was he motivated by religious fervor, by homophobia, by both? I remember asking similar questions after the shooting in San Bernardino last year. Many people first thought that a disgruntled employee was behind that attack. Later, we learned the killers had pledged allegiance to the Islamic State. The truth is, we may never fully understand. Some terrorists may be motivated solely by religious fervor. Others might be cloaking personal grievances in the garb of something grander. In fact, capitalizing on the personal frustrations of potential recruits is an explicit strategy of the Islamic State, according to anthropologist Scott Atron,
他是出于对宗教狂热的驱使、恐同心理，还是两者兼有？我还记得去年圣贝纳迪诺枪击案发生后，我也曾提出过类似的问题。许多人最初认为那起袭击是由心怀不满的员工发起的。后来，我们才得知凶手曾宣誓效忠“伊斯兰国”。事实是，我们可能永远无法完全理解。有些恐怖分子可能完全出于宗教狂热的驱动。另一些人则可能将个人的满腹牢骚披上更宏大的外衣。事实上，人类学家斯科特·阿特兰表示，利用潜在招募对象的个人挫败感正是“伊斯兰国”的明确战略。
who has studied the group. The strategy of the Islamic State is quite simple and very well spelled out. We will find out who in our enemy populations have grievances, have frustrated personal aspirations. We will draw that out, and we will wed it to the story we have of how the world should change and why. This week we're going to share an episode we ran some months ago about why young people turn to terrorism and mass murder. Not all the ideas in this episode speak directly to the Orlando shooting, but they're instructive because they highlight the psychological processes that drive people to theatrical displays of brutality and violence.
他曾对该组织进行过研究。“伊斯兰国”的战略非常简单，也阐述得十分清楚。我们将找出敌方人口中谁心怀不满、个人抱负受挫。我们会把这些情绪引导出来，并将其与我们编造的关于世界应该如何改变以及为何改变的故事结合起来。本周我们将分享几个月前播出的一集节目，探讨年轻人为何会走向恐怖主义和大规模谋杀。本集节目中的某些观点并非直接针对奥兰多枪击案，但它们极具启发性，因为它们突显了驱使人们做出戏剧性野蛮和暴力行为的心理过程。
We're going to use Atron's anthropological lens and studies on would-be suicide bombers by an Israeli psychologist to explore the attraction of terrorist outfits in faraway lands. But even for those who never travel far from home, there are striking psychological similarities between radicalization and what some experts call self-radicalization. As we come to terms with the horror of what unfolded in Orlando, you may want to think of this episode as a primer on some of the counterintuitive conclusion social scientists are reaching as they study the nature of modern terrorism.
我们将借助阿特兰的人类学视角以及以色列心理学家对潜在自杀式袭击者的研究，来探讨遥远国度的恐怖主义组织究竟有何吸引力。然而，即便对于那些从未远行离开家乡的人来说，激进化与某些专家所称的“自我激进化”之间也存在着惊人的心理相似性。在我们正视奥兰多惨剧所带来的恐怖之的同时，你不妨将这集节目视为一本入门读物，了解社会学家在研究现代恐怖主义本质时得出的一些出人意料的结论。
I got a call from the medical school in Cartoum the other day where professor at the medical school said that her best students have just gone on to found a medical unit for the Islamic State and this was completely unexpected in what she'd do about it. What should the school do about it? This is Scott Atron. He's an anthropologist who works at the University of Oxford, the University of Michigan, and the French National Center for Scientific Research.
几天前我接到了喀土穆医学院的电话，医学院的一位教授说她最优秀的学生刚刚去为“伊斯兰国”建立了一个医疗队，这在她看来完全出乎意料，她不知道该怎么处理。学校应该怎么做？这就是斯科特·阿特兰。他是一位人类学家，在牛津大学、密歇根大学以及法国国家科学研究中心工作。
He has traveled to the front lines of war zones, to cafes in Morocco and housing projects in the Paris suburbs. He has spent many years trying to understand why people are drawn to join groups such as ISIS, which is also known as the Islamic State. As I get a call saying, we you talk to us, our students, we don't understand this, they were our best students, our brightest students.
他曾亲赴战火纷飞的前线，走访摩洛哥的咖啡馆以及巴黎郊区的经济适用房小区。多年来，他一直试图弄明白，为什么人们会被吸引加入诸如ISIS（也被称为“伊斯兰国”）这样的组织。我接到电话说：“你们能和我们谈谈吗？我们的学生，我们不理解这是为什么，他们是我们最优秀的学生，最聪明的学生。”
And they went off to establish a medical clinic. We found out that with the Islamic State, their parents are hysterical. We don't know what to tell them. Can you tell us what's going on? The students were of Sudanese ancestry and most had British passports. They came from well to do families. They had promising careers ahead of them. Families of the medical students were dumb struck. The heartbroken sister of one student spoke to the daily male in Britain.
“而他们却去建立了一个医疗诊所。”我们发现，“伊斯兰国”成员的父母们都歇斯底里。我们不知道该对他们说些什么。你能告诉我们究竟发生了什么吗？这些学生拥有苏丹血统，大多数人持有英国护照。他们出身优渥的家庭。他们的前途一片光明。医学院学生的家属们目瞪口呆。其中一名学生心碎的妹妹接受了英国《每日邮报》的采访。
And we just want her home, we want her safe. Her family love her more than anybody else in this world can. Nobody in this world can love her more than we do. My little sister, she's an A star student. They're praying on young innocent girls and it's not right. Atron said he told the teachers at the medical school, the same thing he has been preaching for years to governments and more recently at the United Nations.
我们只想要她回家，我们想要她平平安安。她的家人比这世上的任何人都要爱她。这世上没有人能比我们更爱她。我的小妹妹，她是一个门门拿A的优等生。他们在捕食年轻无辜的女孩，这太不对了。阿特兰表示，他告诉医学院的老师们的话，正是他多年来一直向各国政府乃至最近在联合国苦口婆心宣讲的内容。
I said, listen, I can't give you the solution. The solution has to be for you to pay attention to listen to what they're telling you. I mean, obviously if you had listened to them and engaged with them, you would have had indications of what was happening and you would have been you had listened to them and engaged with them, you would have had indications of what was happening and you would have been able to talk to them. But like parents, the older authorities again know nothing and again are preaching nonsense things like moderation or this isn't true Islam or whatever baloney they're giving them today. And of course it
我说：“听着，我给不了你们解决方案。解决方案必须是你们去关注、去倾听他们正在对你们说的话。我的意思是，很明显，如果你们早点倾听他们并与他们沟通，你们就会掌握正在发生的事情的蛛丝马迹，你们就会……如果你们早点倾听他们并与他们沟通，你们就会掌握正在发生的事情的蛛丝马迹，并且你们本能够与他们交流。但就像父母一样，年长的权威们又是一无所知，又在宣扬一些诸如‘要温和’或者‘这不是真正的伊斯兰教’之类的荒谬言论，或者他们今天给出的任何废话。当然，这”
means nothing. Meaning, it is an effective. It's falling on deaf ears. Atron believes these messages won't be effective because they fundamentally misunderstand why the young medical students were drawn to the Islamic State. The authorities painted the recruits as drawn to nihilism. Atron thinks it has more to do with a twisted idealism. The Islamic State revolution is a revolution. There really isn't much difference I see in the impulse or the impetus to the Islamic State Revolution, then to the French Revolution, or to the Bolshevik Revolution, or to the National Socialist Revolution, and it appeals to the same sorts of people.
毫无意义。也就是说，它是无效的。这简直是是对牛弹琴。阿特兰认为这些信息之所以无效，是因为它们从根本上误解了年轻医学生被“伊斯兰国”吸引的原因。当局将这些新兵描绘成被虚无主义所吸引。而阿特兰认为，这更多与一种扭曲的理想主义有关。“伊斯兰国”的革命是一场革命。在我看来，“伊斯兰国”革命的冲动或动因，与法国革命、布尔什维克革命或国家社会主义革命并没有太大区别，它吸引的也是同类人。
Comparing the Islamic State to the French Revolution, or the Bolshevik Revolution, doesn't mean it will succeed. Lots of revolutions fail. But if Aatron is right, it does mean that it would be a big mistake to underestimate the draw of the Islamic state. In one ISIS video, a young British man looks into the camera. He has a status scope around his neck. He leans in with an earnest expression. All the people in England ask you again,
将“伊斯兰国”与法国大革命或布尔什维克革命进行比较，并不意味着它一定会成功。许多革命都以失败告终。但如果阿特兰是对的，这就意味着低估“伊斯兰国”的吸引力将是一个巨大的错误。在一段ISIS的视频中，一名年轻的英国男子注视着镜头。他的脖子上挂着听诊器。他带着真诚的表情向前倾身。在英格兰的所有人，我再次请求你们，
all the Muslims over there, toqullah, leave the land of England and come to make it to here, and we'll like to hear and endure it to Islam, and help your brothers and sisters out here. Allah, He there, there is a great cause being fought here, and the caravan is leaving. George Orwell, in his review of mine, come back in 1939. I'm not crazy about that
那里的所有穆斯林，敬畏真主（toqullah），离开英格兰的土地，来到这里实现迁徙，我们很乐意在这里听从并忍耐伊斯兰教，并在这里帮助你们的兄弟姐妹。真主，祂在那里，这里正在进行一项伟大的事业，车队正在出发。乔治·欧威尔在1939年对《我的奋斗》的评论中写道。我并不是很迷恋那个
Hitalariums, but this was a particularly insightful piece. He said, what is it about Mr. Hitler that appeals? What is the essence of the problem? Look at our societies, capitalist societies, offer their people, ease, avoidance of risk and pain, security, and short the good life. And what is the result? Well, the Oxford Student Union, the cream of our intellectuals, votes they will never fight again. And Mr. Hitler, what is he offering his people? Glory?
希特勒主义，但这确实是一篇特别有见地的文章。他说：“希特勒先生究竟有什么吸引人的地方？问题的实质是什么？看看我们的社会，资本主义社会为人民提供的是：安逸、规避风险和痛苦、安全，以及确定无疑的美好生活。结果是什么呢？嗯，牛津大学学生联合会——我们知识分子的精英，投票决定他们绝不再战。而希特勒先生，他为他的人民提供的是什么？荣耀？”
Adventure? Even death and destruction, but most of all transcendence and a feeling of self-sacrifice. So Mr. Hitler has understood the essence of human beings. Human beings need not just short working hours, and comfort, and security, and avoidance of pain, they need at least intermittently a feeling of transcendence and self-sacrifice. And so 80 million people now fall down at his feet. And in fact, the German soldiers in World War II outfought on any measure the Allied soldiers, be they Russian or American or Brits.
“冒险？甚至是死亡与毁灭，但最重要的是超越感和自我牺牲感。”所以希特勒先生抓住了人类的本质。人类不仅需要短暂的工作时间、舒适、安全和逃避痛苦，他们至少间歇性地需要一种超越感和自我牺牲感。于是8000万人类现在拜倒在他的脚下。事实上，无论用什么标准来衡量，二战中的德国士兵都比盟军士兵（无论是俄国人、美国人还是英国人）打得更顽强。
Scott Atron says he sees the same conviction among Islamic state fighters. He was recently talking with Kurdish and Iraqi soldiers, a short distance from the front lines in the battle with ISIS. The Islamic state came in June of 2014 in about 80 trucks of four to five people at truck, about 350 people, to free a prison by the ocean. Because freeing prisoners gained your recruits. They also massacred 600 Shia in that prison. But the Iraqi army, trained by the United States, armed by the United States to the tune
斯科特·阿特兰表示，他在“伊斯兰国”战士身上也看到了同样的信念。他最近与库尔德和伊拉克士兵交谈过，地点距离与ISIS战斗的前线不远。“伊斯兰国”于2014年6月开着大约80辆卡车（每辆卡车四到五人，共约350人）赶来，目的是解放海滨的一座监狱。因为解放囚犯能为你赢得新兵。他们还在那座监狱里屠杀了600名什叶派穆斯林。然而，由美国训练、由美国武装到牙齿的伊拉克军队，耗资
of billions of dollars, simply ran away. Now there was one unit on the Mahmour Front in a place called Karamedi, where we had a few Iraqi soldiers embedded with the Peshmerga. And the reason they stayed was because their families actually lived in villages close by. And I asked them, why is it that your fellow soldiers simply ran away or melted into the city? And one said to me, they simply didn't want their heads cut off. When we hear reports of beheadings or prisoners being set on fire, the Islamic states seemingly
达数十亿美元，却落荒而逃。现在，在迈穆尔前线一个叫卡拉梅迪的地方有一个部队，我们有一些伊拉克军队与佩什梅格并肩作战。他们留下来是因为他们的家人实际上就住在附近的村庄里。我问他们：“为什么你们的战友会落荒而逃，或者融入城市中消失不见？”其中一个人对我说：“他们只是不想被砍头。”当我们听到斩首或囚犯被放火焚烧的报道时，“伊斯兰国”看似
in discriminant violence shock us, but the shock can keep us from seeing that such theatrical displays of brutality actually serve psychological goals. The spilling of blood, the brutality accomplish accomplishes two things, and usually has done that throughout the human history and across cultures. First of all, it binds people together who are doing it, and the second thing it does is it scares the hell out of enemies and fence-setters. Coming up, we'll hear about a parent of a British medical student who left a promising career to join the Islamic State. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When British engineer Ahmad Mutana realized his medical student son had left the family home in Cardiff in the
不分青红皂白的暴力行为震惊了我们，但这种震惊可能会让我们忽视这样一个事实：这种极具戏剧性的野蛮展示实际上服务于心理目标。流血和野蛮达到了两个目的，而且通观人类历史和跨越不同文化，通常一直都在发挥这样的作用。首先，它将施暴的人紧紧地团结在一起；其次，它把敌人和骑墙派吓得魂飞魄散。接下来，我们将听到一位英国医学生的父母的故事，这名学生曾放弃了大好前程去加入“伊斯兰国”。请继续收听。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当英国工程师艾哈迈德·穆塔纳意识到他的医学生儿子已经离开位于英国卡迪夫的家去加入“伊斯兰国”时，
United Kingdom to join the Islamic State. He was enraged. Police came to his home and showed him a video of his son, Nasser, trying to recruit others to join ISIS. I feel sick and devastated that my son is caught up in this. He told Daily Mail. He was brought up to love and respect my country, which is Britain. I am his father, and naturally I am worried about his safety while he is out there, but I am also worried about the evil messages
他勃然大怒。警察来到他家里，向他展示了一段他儿子纳赛尔试图招募其他人加入ISIS的视频。得知我的儿子卷入其中，我感到恶心和心碎。他告诉《每日邮报》。他从小就被培养去热爱和尊重我的祖国——英国。我是他的父亲，当他在外面时，我自然担心他的安全，但我也担心他在这段视频中传播的邪恶信息。”
he is spreading in this video." Muthana said he rid his house of photographs of NASA, saying, It's a Muslim thing, you can do to make a living? Atron thinks it's understandable that parents would express shock, disbelief, and anger. But he thinks a more productive approach is to look at the young people drawn to terrorist groups with a measure of empathy. By empathizing, I mean listening to people, trying to understand where they're coming from, why they believe what they do and act the way they do,
穆塔纳说，他把家里的纳赛尔的照片都清理掉了，并说：“这是一件穆斯林的事，你能靠它谋生吗？”阿特兰认为，父母表现出震惊、难以置信和愤怒是可以理解的。但他认为，更富有成效的方法是以某种程度的同理心来看待被恐怖组织吸引的年轻人。通过共情，我的意思是倾听人们的心声，试着理解他们的立场、他们为什么会持有某种信念以及他们为什么会有这种行为，
without necessarily sympathizing in the sense that you don't have to agree with them. In fact, you may have to fight them, but it's always better to understand where they're coming from, even in order to fight them. Atron says his approach was inspired by the great anthropologist Margaret Mead and the dictum of an ancient Roman playwright. In recent testimony that you provided at the United Nations, you talked about something that you had learned from Margaret Meade, whom you worked with in New York many years ago. What exactly did Margaret Meade teach you?
这并不一定意味着要产生同情，也就是说你不需要赞同他们。事实上，你可能不得不与他们战斗，但了解他们的立场总是更好的，哪怕是为了与他们战斗。阿特兰说，他的方法受到了伟大人类学家玛格丽特·米德以及古代罗马剧作家的一句名言的启发。在您最近于联合国提供的证词中，您谈到了您多年前在纽约与玛格丽特·米德共事时学到的一些东西。玛格丽特·米德究竟教给了您什么？
Well, she taught me that anthropology is basically a response, at least it was then. Basically a to a Terence's dictum, nothing human is alien to me. Violent people, members of militant political groups and religious groups are people, just like everyone else. I want to take you back to something you told me a second ago. I just want to go back to this issue of empathizing versus sympathizing, because when I look at the behavior of the Islamic state and you sort of see this wanton disregard for human life, the deliberate cruelty, the beheadings,
嗯，她教导我，人类学基本上是一种回应，至少当时是这样。基本上是对泰伦斯名言的回应：“凡是与人有关的事物，对我而言都不陌生。”暴力分子、激进政治团体和宗教团体的成员也是人，和所有人一样。我想带你回到你刚才告诉我的一件事上。我只想回到共情与同情这个议题上来，因为当我看到“伊斯兰国”的行为，看到这种对人生命的肆意践踏、蓄意的残忍、斩首、
the rape, the enslavement of people, it's hard to bring yourself to think about empathizing with people who do this. Yes, it is. And that's why being an anthropologist often requires a special commitment to that sort of empathy. In the conventional narrative of how young people get recruited to groups such as ISIS, shadowy recruiters go and search of vulnerable people. Atron and psychologist Aria and Marari think this isn't the way it usually happens.
强奸和奴役人类时，你很难让自己去体谅那些做出这些事的人。是的，确实很难。正因如此，作为一名人类学家，往往需要对这种共情做出特殊的承诺。在关于年轻人如何被招募加入ISIS等组织的传统叙事中，隐秘的招募人员会去寻找脆弱的人。阿特兰和心理学家阿里安·马拉里认为，这通常不是事情发生的方式。
In a study he has conducted in Israel among captured prisoners, Morari has interviewed a number of would-be suicide bombers. For various reasons, these recruits didn't carry out their missions. Their equipment didn't work or they were caught before they could carry out an attack. Morari finds religious extremism is rarely a central motivator for these young people. He says most are driven by the political goal of ending the Israeli occupation. Now the political goals of Palestinian recruits fighting the Israeli occupation are different
在他于以色列被捕囚犯中进行的的一项研究中，马拉里采访了多名潜在的自杀式袭击者。出于各种原因，这些新兵没有执行任务。他们的装备失灵了，或者他们在发动袭击之前就被抓获了。马拉里发现，宗教极端主义很少是这些年轻人核心的驱动力。他说，大多数人都是由结束以色列占领这一政治目标所驱动的。现在，抗击以色列占领的巴勒斯坦新兵的政治目标与
than the political goals of ISIS recruits, but Marari's research shows there are underlying similarities in the psychological appeal of these groups. As in the case of ISIS, many Palestinian recruits report they are radicalized, not in mosques, but in university cafeterias. Well, just imagine a young Palestinian 16, 17, 18, 20 years old. If it's with his friends in the universities of the cafeteria, they are talking about yesterday's suicide attack that took place in Jerusalem. And everybody is saying what the great thing, the guy that did it, how brave he was, how patriotic, a hero. And one of the guys here, or perhaps more than one, is an important young man, marginal in his own social circle.
ISIS新兵的政治目标有所不同，但马拉里的研究表明，这些组织在心理吸引力上存在着潜在的相似性。正如ISIS的情况一样，许多巴勒斯坦新兵报告说，他们走向激进化不是在清真寺里，而是在大学的自助餐厅里。嗯，试想一下一个16、17、18、20岁的年轻巴勒斯坦人。如果他和朋友们在大学的自助餐厅里，他们正在谈论昨天在耶路撒冷发生的自杀式袭击。每个人都在说那是一件多么伟大的事，那个实施袭击的人是多么勇敢，多么爱国，简直是个英雄。这里的一个人，或者可能不止一个人，是一个重要的年轻人，在自己的社交圈子里处于边缘地位。
But he wants to be recognized as somebody. He wants to be appreciated. So he says, hey, you know, I would also carry out this, so he's at a tech. Someone over here is the boast, and word gets back to the commander of a group looking for recruits. The commander sends for the young man. This 17, 18, 19 years old, youngster stands in front of these elder commander revered, famous admired commander and the commander has seen. I heard that you were willing to carry out
但他渴望得到某个人的认可。他渴望被赏识。于是他说：“嘿，你知道吗，我也会执行这个，所以他是发袭击者。”这里有人在吹牛，这些话传到了一个正在寻找新兵的组织指挥官耳中。指挥官派人找来了这个年轻人。这个17、18、19岁的年轻人站在这些备受尊崇、大名鼎鼎、令人敬仰的长者指挥官面前，而指挥官看到并说道：“我听说你愿意执行
a suicide attack. They don't call it suicide, of course. They call it a martyr, they don't mean it. It's the truth. Now, what would the other, that young guy say? No, I was just bragging. He says, oh yes, of course, and he thinks, well, perhaps something will happen and they won't have to carry it out eventually. The single best predictor of whether someone gets involved in a terrorist organization
一次自杀式袭击。”当然，他们不叫自杀。他们称之为烈士，他们不是开玩笑的。这是真的。现在，那个年轻家伙会怎么说？“不，我只是吹牛的。”他会说：“哦，是的，当然，”他心里想，嗯，也许会发生点什么，最终他们就不必去执行了。预测某人是否会加入恐怖组织的最佳单一指标是
is that their friends and peers are also involved. In the case of the medical students, waves of British Sudanese students have headed out to Syria. Akron told me that ISIS has explicitly laid out a path to gaining younger recruits from around the world. The strategy of the Islamic State is quite simple and very well spelled out. And it is, first of all, take advantage wherever there is chaos in the world. Create chaos wherever the enemy allows us to do. And how do we do that?
他们的朋友和同龄人也参与其中。以那些医学生为例，一波又一波的英籍苏丹学生前往叙利亚。阿特兰告诉我，ISIS已经明确规划了一条从世界各地招募年轻新兵的途径。“伊斯兰国”的战略非常简单，也阐述得十分清楚。首先，利用世界上任何存在混乱的地方。在敌人允许我们这样做的任何地方制造混乱。我们该怎么做呢？
Well, in places like Europe, what we're going to do is attack tourist centers, cafes, theaters, stadiums. Why? Because these types of places cannot possibly be defended. There are just too many of them. There are too few security agencies and law enforcement. So it will terrorize the population and cause the states against us to disperse their resources in reckless ways that cannot possibly help them in the end. Second, we will appeal to the youth,
嗯，在欧洲这样的大陆，我们要做的就是袭击旅游中心、咖啡馆、剧院、体育场。为什么？因为这些地方根本无法防守。数量实在太多了。安保机构和执法力量又太少。因此，这将恐吓民众，并导致与我们为敌的国家以最终对他们毫无帮助的鲁莽方式分散资源。其次，我们将吸引年轻人，
the rebelliousness, the idealism, the adventure, the search for glory, the desire for change that youth have. While the fools, they say, will preach moderation, wasatia, which is exactly what's been happening. We will offer them something great. And so what the Islamic State does, and this explains why many of those people in Europe, young people are coming, and from many other countries in the world, including the United States,
吸引他们的叛逆心、理想主义、冒险精神、对荣耀的追寻、年轻人所拥有的对改变的渴望。而那些傻瓜们却说，要去宣扬温和（wasatia），这恰恰就是正在发生的事情。我们将为他们提供伟大的事物。“伊斯兰国”所做的这一切——这也解释了为什么欧洲的许多年轻人、以及来自世界上许多其他国家（包括美国）的年轻人会来到这里——
is we will find out who in our enemy populations have grievances, have frustrated personal aspirations, have a need for something glorious, something that transcends themselves. We will draw that out and we will wed it to the story we have of how the world should change and why. Over and over, Atron says, he finds that foreign recruits to the Islamic State are often marginal members of their own societies, people who feel like outsiders. Again, the Islamic State's message, why they're so good at it, is they take each of these personal stories, which will invest hundreds of hours in, and try to show why my personal frustration, your personal frustration, at this moment in your life.
就是我们要找出敌方人口中谁心怀不满、个人抱负受挫、需要某种宏大的事物、某种能超越自身的事物。我们将把这些情绪引导出来，并将其与我们编造的关于世界应该如何改变以及为何改变的故事结合起来。阿特兰一遍又一遍地发现，加入“伊斯兰国”的外籍新兵往往是其自身社会的边缘成员，是那些觉得自己像局外人的人。再次强调，“伊斯兰国”之所以擅长此道，是因为他们会了解每个人的个人故事，为此投入数百个小时，并试图阐明为什么我个人的挫折、你个人的挫折，在你人生的这个特定时刻，
It's not because you couldn't get this job or you failed in this or your team lost or whatever. The reason that happened, you see, is because of this larger set of factors, of this larger world set of forces that have been arrayed against you, of which this is just a trivial part and forget about the trivial parts that affecting your life. Go now and deal with forces that have been arrayed against you, of which this is just a trivial part and forget about the trivial parts that are affecting your life. Go now and deal with the real causes of the unhappiness, not only of you, but of people like you around the world, the oppressed.
并不是因为你找不到工作，或者你在这件事上失败了，或者你支持的球队输了，诸如此类。你看，之所以发生这种情况，是因为有一套更大规模的因素、这套庞大的世界力量矩阵在针对你，而你经历的这些只是其中微不足道的一部分，别去管那些影响你生活的微不足道的部分了。现在就去对抗那些针对你的力量吧，而你经历的这些只是其中微不足道的部分，别去管那些影响你生活微不足道的部分了。现在就去应对导致你以及世界各地像你一样的人——那些被压迫者——不幸福的真正根源。
When families of students who join the Islamic State appeal to them to come to their senses, the pleas are often ineffective because the young people have found the cause they think is greater than their parents, greater than their families, greater even than themselves. You can see the same behavior among followers and other groups, and not just terrorist organizations, even non-violent groups fighting for social justice. What we find, and this is not just true for the Islamic State, this is true for people who are willing to sacrifice their lives and kill others at the same time across the board.
当加入“伊斯兰国”的学生的家属呼吁他们清醒过来时，这些恳求往往无济于事，因为这些年轻人已经找到了他们认为比父母更伟大、比家庭更伟大、甚至比他们自身更伟大的事业。你可以在追随其他群体的追随者身上看到同样的行径，不仅是恐怖组织，甚至包括为社会正义而战的非暴力组织。我们发现，这不仅适用于“伊斯兰国”，这也适用于全面愿意牺牲自己生命并同时杀死他人的人。
And it's also true for movements that are peaceful, but where the people who are driving these movements are willing to shed their own blood. For example, the civil rights movement or movements like Gandhi's movement in India, they are committed to a set of values which are sacred. That means values which are immune to trade-offs. For example, you would not change your children, or your religion, probably, or your country for all the money in China. And when you have these kinds of values which you will not trade off, and which are not subject to the standard constraints of material life, things that occurred in the distant past or in distant places that are sacred are actually more important
这也适用于那些和平的运动，但推动这些运动的人愿意抛洒自己的热血。例如，民权运动或印度甘地的运动，他们致力于一组神圣的价值观。这意味着这些价值观不受权衡取舍的影响。例如，你不会为了全中国的财富而把你的孩子、你的宗教或者很可能还有你的国家换掉。当你拥有这种不会拿去权衡取舍、且不受物质生活标准约束的价值观时，发生在遥远过去或遥远地方的那些神圣的事情，实际上比此时此地的事务
than things in the here and now. They're also oblivious to quantity. It doesn't matter if I kill one or I attract one or a thousand or no one as long as my intention is good and righteous. And once you lock into these values, they're immune to social pressures, they're not norms. That is, even if you're best friends, your family, your loved ones are against you, you will not see an exit strategy. Scott Atron has conducted psychological experiments with captured Islamic State fighters on the battlefield. We were in Kierkuk.
更加重要。它们也对数量视而不见。只要我的意图是善良和正义的，我杀一个人、一千个人还是一个人都不杀，都无关紧要。一旦你认准了这些价值观，它们就会免疫于社会压力，它们不是规范。也就是说，即使你最好的朋友、你的家人、你所爱的人都反对你，你也绝不会看到退路。斯科特·阿特兰在战场上对被俘的“伊斯兰国”战士进行了心理实验。我们在基尔库克。
So there's a front there, mud walls that extend for a thousand kilometers and about every kilometer there's a mud turret with about twenty fighters inside and that's where we were working. And we got a hold of some captured Islamic State fighters and we ran these experiments. In one set of experiments, Atron evaluated how much a fighter had adopted the identity of the group over all the other identities the person might have. Atron and his colleagues found that when a fighter's identity fuses with the identity of the group, there is a psychological change that occurs.
那里有一条前线，泥墙延伸了一千公里，大约每隔一公里就有一个泥砌的瞭望塔，里面大约有二十名战士，我们当时就在那里工作。我们抓到了一些被俘的“伊斯兰国”战士，并对他们进行了这些实验。在一组实验中，阿特兰评估了一个战士在多大程度上将该团体的身份认同融入了自己可能拥有的所有其他身份认同中。阿特兰和他的同事发现，当一个战士的身份与团体的身份融合时，就会发生一种心理变化。
We have many identities. We may be American, or Indian, or Red Sox fans, or Yankee fans, or lawyers, or doctors, or whatever we are today or tomorrow, but they have only one identity, and they will fight and die, not just for that group, but for every single individual in that group. And once this happens, we also have other measures which show they develop a sense of invincibility and actually perceive themselves their own bodies to be much bigger than they actually are and they perceive the other group to be much weaker. This idea has a lot of support elsewhere in the social sciences.
我们有许多身份。我们可能是美国人、印度人、红袜队球迷、洋基队球迷、律师、医生，或者无论我们今天或明天是什么身份，但他们只有一个身份，他们会为了这个团体而战并牺牲，不仅是为了这个团体，也是为了这个团体中的每一个成员。一旦发生这种情况，我们还有其他指标表明，他们会产生一种无敌感，并且实际上认为自己——他们自己的身体——比实际情况要大得多，而他们认为对方的群体要弱得多。这个观点在社会科学的其他领域得到了很多支持。
In some ways, being part of a group is a way of creating an immortal version of yourself. When you remind people of their mortality, for example, they express stronger support for the groups to which they belong. You may die, but your identity in the group will outlive you. I asked Atron and Marari about how they would apply what they have learned to doing battle with the Islamic State. I think it's very important if you want to fight effectively against a militant Islam you have first of all to defeat it physically.
在某种程度上，成为群体的一部分是创造一个永恒版本的自我的一种方式。例如，当你提醒人们他们的死亡率时，他们会对他们所属的群体表达更强烈的支持。你可能会死，但你在群体中的身份将比你活得更久。我问阿特兰和马拉里，他们将如何把学到的知识应用到与“伊斯兰国”的战斗中。我认为，如果你想有效地打击激进的伊斯兰教，首先必须在物理上击败它，这一点非常重要。
Despite what people say about hearts and minds, you know, in the Second World War there was a Russian Soviet ambassador in London. His name was Maiski, Ivan Mysky. And once somebody asked Ambassador Mysky, what is the good psychological warfare talking about parts in mind? What's a good psychological warfare? And Mysky replied, a good psychological warfare is facts and figures, facts being victories and figures being dead Germans. And I think in a bit more moderate sense, this applies also to the current situation.
尽管人们对“人心所向”夸夸其谈，但你知道，在二战期间，伦敦有一位俄罗斯苏联大使。他的名字叫迈斯基，伊万·迈斯基。曾经有人问迈斯基大使：“谈论人心所向的好的心理战是什么？什么是好的心理战？”迈斯基回答说：“好的心理战就是事实和数据，事实是胜利，数据是死去的德国人。”我认为，以一种稍微温和的方式，这也适用于当前的情况。
If you want to effectively fight ISIS, first of all, the fit ISIS in the territory that it has occupied successfully. That's the first thing you have to do. And I don't understand why the West hasn't done it yet. Atron says psychological weapons might also be needed to fight ISIS. Preaching the virtues of moderation isn't going to work. They think things will work out and telling them, again and again, this is in the true Islam. That alone isn't going to do it.
如果你想有效地打击ISIS，首先要在它成功占领的领土上击败ISIS。这是你必须做的第一件事。我不明白为什么西方到现在还没有这样做。阿特兰表示，打击ISIS可能还需要心理武器。宣扬温和的美德是行不通的。他们认为事情会有结果，并且一遍又一遍地告诉他们“这不是真正的伊斯兰教”。单靠这一点是无法成功的。
You've got to get into their networks. You've got to befriend them. You've got to get the friends of, it's like smoking. It's not showing them pictures of cancerous esophagy that are going to stop people from smoking. It's young people getting other young people to stop smoking. Of course, there can be constraining laws and barriers to smoking, but what will really stop them is if their friends have stopped.
你必须打入他们的网络。你必须与他们交朋友。你必须让……这就好比吸烟。阻止人们吸烟的不是向他们展示癌症食道的图片。而是年轻人让其他年轻人停止吸烟。当然，可以有约束性的法律和禁烟障碍，但真正能阻止他们的，是他们的朋友们都戒烟了。
Two brothers, Ibrahim and Muhammad Ajid, are thought to be among the British medical students who left Sudan to join the Islamic State in Syria. They left right before they were supposed to take their final exams in their last year of medical school. The last post on Muhammad's Facebook page is from December 30th, 2014. Most of his posts are of funny videos, pictures of his brother and friends, and soccer teams. Muhammad as 480 friends, likes cold play and the fresh prince of Bel Air. Abraham has 546 friends. He likes Manchester United, Beyonce and Eminem,
据信，易卜拉欣和穆罕默德·阿吉德这两兄弟是离开苏丹前往叙利亚加入“伊斯兰国”的英国医学生之一。他们在医学院最后一年的期末考试前夕离开了。穆罕默德的Facebook页面上的最后一条动态发布于2014年12月30日。他的大部分动态都是搞笑视频、他和兄弟朋友的照片以及足球队的照片。穆罕默德有480个好友，喜欢酷玩乐队（Coldplay）和《新鲜王子妙事多》（The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air）。易卜拉欣有546个好友。他喜欢曼联、碧昂丝和埃米纳姆，
and the TV shows, The Boondocks, and Everybody Hates Chris. News reports show that recruits are not allowed to leave the Islamic State if they dislike what they find when they get to Syria. The disloyal are often executed. The British medical students who left Sudan are in touch with their parents through social media apps. They offer few details of what they are doing except to say they are using their medical training.
以及电视剧《黑门》（The Boondocks）和《人人都恨克里斯》（Everybody Hates Chris）。新闻报道显示，如果新兵到了叙利亚后对那里的一切感到不满，是不被允许离开“伊斯兰国”的。不忠诚者通常会被处决。离开苏丹的英国医学生正通过社交媒体应用程序与父母保持联系。他们很少透露自己正在做什么的细节，只是说他们正在运用他们的医学培训。
Sometimes they send texts which short audio messages. To their waiting families, these messages feel terse and uninformed. They don't sound like the young people they used to be. Their parents say they sound different. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Max Nestrak, Maggie Pennman, Chris Banderayf and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks this week to Walter Ray Watson and Daniel Schuchin. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram. You can also listen to my work on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes or wherever you listen
有时他们发送带有简短音频信息的短信。对于苦苦等待的家属来说，这些信息显得生硬且缺乏信息量。他们听起来已经不再是以前那些年轻人了。他们的父母说他们听起来不一样了。“隐藏的大脑”由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛、马克·内斯特拉克、玛吉·佩恩曼、克里斯·班德拉伊夫和珍妮·施密特制作。本周特别感谢沃尔特·雷·沃森和丹尼尔·舒钦。想要了解更多“隐藏的大脑”，你可以在推特、脸书和照片墙上关注我们。你还可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。如果你喜欢这集节目，考虑在苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方给我们写个评价。
to your podcasts. It'll help others find the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这将帮助其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。本集节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。